gastroesophageal reflux disease
commonly known as gerd and related
disorders due to acid hypersecretion
are one of the most prevalent disorders
of gi tract
in our world nowadays recent data
estimates show
that over 30 adults in western countries
suffer from these problems
this means out of every 10 people you
meet three
are likely to be suffering from one or
other kind of acid related disorders
and if you're one of them it's very
likely that you have taken drugs like
pen top
pantosid trillosec nexium
xantac etc what are these drugs
well these drugs belong to a common
family known as the proton pump
inhibitors
proton pump inhibitors also known as
ppis
stop the secretion of acid in your
stomach they do so by blocking the main
acid-producing channels
in the cells of your stomach and they
are quite effective in that
you may not know it but the introduction
of proton pump inhibitors into clinical
practice
has revolutionized the management of
acid reflux diseases
ppis remain the leading evidence-based
therapy
for acid-related diseases including gerd
peptic ulcer disease dyspepsia
anti-inflammatory drug induced ulcer
helicobacter pylori infection and
hypersecurity disorders such as
zollinger allison syndrome
earlier the only treatment available for
these used to be highly invasive and
unreliable surgeries
proton pump inhibitors have been on the
market since late 1980s and remain
till late the most potent drugs for the
treatment of acid-related diseases
even though they have proven to be
highly safe no drug exists without a
side effect or a drawback decades of
extensive research and trials have
clearly shown
long-term side effects of ppis but the
fact is
ppis are the most abused drug in the
world
hello i'm dr umar malik and welcome to
math simplified
in our previous videos we talked about
how and why acid reflux occurs
and the various foods and preventive
measures to control acid reflux
in case you haven't watched those videos
click the link in the description box to
watch those videos first to have a
better understanding of this topic
in this video we'll be talking about the
potential side effects of proton pump
inhibitors
abuse and overuse so let's begin
in 2018 100 million prescriptions were
written for ppis in united states alone
this will roughly give you an idea about
the amount of overuse
in march 2013 the american college of
gastroenterology released guidelines for
the diagnosis and treatment of gerd
these guidelines provided some insight
into the monitoring for long-term
consequence of chronic ppi use in a
nutshell
long-term consequence of chronic ppi use
can be grouped into two main categories
mal absorption and infections let's take
a deeper look
the first potential long-term
consequence of chronic ppi use
is mild absorption of key minerals in
the body
namely calcium and magnesium deficiency
of calcium leads to hypocalcemia
calcium serves as an important role in
bone health and formation
as it is a key component and a
structural element of bone
also bone material is a major reservoir
for calcium and contains around 99
percent of the body's calcium
long-term ppi use has been associated
with hypocalcemia
which means decreased calcium in the
body this can also lead to confusion
or memory loss muscle spasms numbness
and tingling in the hands feet
and face depression hallucinations
muscle cramps weak and brittle nails
easy fracturing
of bones studies have shown there is an
increased risk of osteoporosis
and decreased bone mineral density with
a 35
increased risk of fractures also the
risk of fractures
increases with the duration and dosage
of ppi use
health canada issued an alert in april
2013
stating that patients with existing risk
factors for osteoporosis
should be monitored closely and should
also receive only short-term ppi therapy
that too are the lowest effective dose
currently
fda also has similar recommendations
this is a matter of great concern
especially in the elderly
who are often affected by multiple
comorbidities and already have very
fragile bones
overuse of ppi can also lead to
hypomagnesemia
in 2011 the fda released a warning
regarding
low serum magnesium levels associated
with long-term use of ppis
this happened to approximately one
percent of patients
symptoms of hypermagnesemia include
seizures heart problems
blood pressure problems muscle weakness
even mental health problems
hypomagnesemia is also potentially fatal
studies show that hypermagnesemia is
generally resolved
when the ppi was discontinued and
reoccurred
soon after the ppi was started fda drug
safety communications
warns of the risk of hypermagnesemia and
recommends that the doctors
must monitor magnesium levels in
patients who are on ppi therapy
once before starting the therapy and
periodically thereafter
now let's look at the second group of
major side effects that can occur with
overuse of ppis
and that is frequent infections in
addition to decreased magnesium and
calcium absorption
patients on long-term ppi therapy may be
at an increased risk of infection
the acid produced by the stomach is not
just important for digestion of food
but it is also important for the defense
mechanism of the stomach
against harmful bacteria that enter our
digestive system
so while ppis effectively reduce acid
they also decrease the natural defense
mechanism that our body has against
foreign invaders
in 2013 american college of
gastroenterologists guidelines
clearly warned about the risk of
increased infection of clostridium
difficile
and pneumonia on long-term bpi use in a
2005 study
researchers found that patients had
around three times increased risk
of acquiring c difficult and were more
likely to have recurrent
infections compared to patients not on
ppi and in 2012
fda issued a statement that wants the
patients and healthcare professionals
to consider clostridium difficult
infection if a patient takes a ppi and
experiences
persistent diarrhea in case of ppi
and pneumonia evidence is a bit
conflicting although data shows that
patients on ppi
are 2.2 times more likely to develop
chest infections
compared to normal public long-term
consequences have not been properly
understood
with around 100 million prescriptions
being filled out for ppis every year
vigilance on part of doctors health care
professionals and patients is
recommended to prevent
chest related and gut related problems
now let's look at another common side
effect that occurs when we stop the ppi
therapy
which is rebound acid hypersecretion
what many physicians fail to advise the
patients
is that once you stop taking ppis after
taking them for about two to three
months
you will experience episodes of rebound
acid reflux
similar to pre-treatment levels
this happens because the acid gets
suppressed for so long
that once ppi is stopped the stomach
goes into an overdrive
and produces massive amounts of acid and
ironically
the only way to relieve this reflux in
extreme cases
is the ppi themselves however this
happens exclusively on long term use
to prevent this it's important to stick
to your physician's decision
of the required time period for your
ppi's therapy
do not overuse ppi because if you do
then you will fall into the cycle of
extreme reflux whenever you stop taking
ppis
doctors agree that most patients with
severe acid reflux disease
need an acid suppressing drug and they
should not be concerned about the side
effects
but millions of people who use ppis for
uncertain indications
there is always the risk of inducing the
symptoms such as reflux
that these drugs are used to treat so to
conclude ppis are efficacious and safe
and multiple studies back this claim
they offer
overwhelming ease for treatment of
various diseases which are previously
thought to be unmanageable
unfortunately like every other drug they
have an athlete's heal
in form of long-term consequences from
continued use
added with the fact that proton pump
inhibitors are available with or without
a prescription
anywhere in the world with hundreds of
millions of people choosing them
on regular basis it's important that we
educate ourselves to effectively prevent
those problems
we at med simplified believe that like
any other drug
you should take the ppis only for the
prescribed amount of time
in the prescribed dosage and the
prescribed schedule this will minimize
the potential side effects and will help
you to move on to non-medication related
management of your reflux problems as a
long-term alternative
thank you so much for watching this
video i hope we taught you something
new about bpis do share this video with
your friends and family who use ppis
if you like this video don't forget to
like and subscribe to our channel
we are committed to bringing you more
content you can support us by becoming a
member on our youtube channel
and on patreon thank you and see you in
the next video